practiquemos un poco la espectroscopia y
r
aquí tenemos tres moléculas un ácido
carboxílicos un alcohol y una amina y
aquí abajo tenemos el espectro y r para
una de estas moléculas identifiquemos a
qué molécula corresponde si dibujamos
una línea en 1500 vamos a enfocarnos en
la región de diagnóstico aquí tenemos la
región del doble enlace y observen que
no tenemos alguna señal en esta región
aquí no tenemos la señal tan fuerte del
estiramiento del carbón y lo así que
podemos descartar al ácido carboxílicos
por otro lado si tenemos algunas señales
del lado izquierdo esta es la región del
enlace con hidrógeno y si dibujamos una
línea en 3000 sabemos que antes de 3000
está la señal que corresponde al
estiramiento del enlace carbono hidro
donde el carbono tiene una hibridación
sp3 aunque eso no nos ayuda mucho en
este caso pero esta otra señal si nos
servirá el centro de esta señal se
encuentra en un número de onda elevado y
observen que es una señal ancha así que
cuando vemos esto podemos pensar en que
hay enlaces con otros hidrógenos esto
corresponde al estiramiento de un h
entonces este espectro corresponde al
alcohol observen que el ácido
carboxílicos tiene un estiramiento o h
similar también esperaríamos una señal
ancha pero como no hay una señal que
corresponda al carbón y lo por eso no
puede ser esta molécula y tampoco puede
ser la amina porque aún cuando tenemos
estiramiento de enlaces nitrógeno
hidrógeno esperaríamos que aparezcan dos
señales una señal para el estiramiento
simétrico
y una para el estiramiento asimétrico
además no tendríamos esta señal tan
ancha así que definitivamente no es la
amina este espectro pertenece a la
molécula de alcohol veamos otras tres
moléculas y un espectro diferente y
empecemos dibujando una línea en 1500 si
analizamos la región del doble enlace
observen que tenemos una señal aunque no
es una señal muy fuerte pero si
dibujamos una línea hacia abajo podemos
ver que se encuentra entre 1600 y 1700
podemos decir que se encuentra
aproximadamente en 1650 entonces tanto
el número de onda como el hecho de que
no es una señal muy fuerte nos llevan a
pensar en que corresponde al
estiramiento de un doble enlace carbono
carbono
ahora si tuviéramos un carbón y lo
esperaríamos ver una señal muy fuerte en
un número de onda mayor a 1700 así que
podemos descartar esta molécula porque
no tenemos una señal para el
estiramiento del carbón yl ahora
analicemos la región del triple enlace
observen que en esta región no aparece
ninguna señal así que tampoco puede ser
esta molécula por lo tanto este espectro
pertenece al ciclo externo si analizamos
la región del enlace con hidrógeno y
dibujamos una línea podemos ver que esta
señal aparece un poco después de 3000 y
corresponde al estiramiento del enlace
carbono hidrógeno donde el carbono tiene
una hibridación sp2 y claro esta señal
corresponde al estiramiento del enlace
carbono hidrógeno donde el carbono tiene
una hibridación
3 entonces el ciclo exe no es la única
molécula que coincide con todas las
señales de este espectro y er hagamos
uno más
aquí tenemos otras tres moléculas y el
espectro y er entonces primero dibujemos
nuestra línea en 1500 vamos a enfocarnos
en el lado izquierdo esta es la región
del doble enlace y observen que tenemos
dos señales muy claras esta señal no es
tan intensa como la otra y se encuentra
aproximadamente entre 1600 y 1700 esos
dos factores nos hacen pensar que esta
señal corresponde al estiramiento de un
doble enlace carbón o carbón
ahora la señal junto a esta se encuentra
en sí aquí es 1600 y 1700 esta señal se
encuentra un poco después de 1700 y es
muy fuerte así que tenemos un carbón y
por lo tanto podemos descartar esta
molécula y nos queda un acetona
conjugada y un acetona no conjugado
primero pensamos en la no conjugado para
el estiramiento de este carbón y lo
esperaríamos encontrar una señal en
aproximadamente 1700 15 es decir después
de 1700 mientras que en la acetona
conjugada observen que hay resonancia y
sabemos que la resonancia disminuye la
fuerza del carbón hilo por lo tanto
disminuye la constante de fuerza acá y
eso disminuye la frecuencia de vibración
por lo que esperaríamos que la señal
para este carbón hilo
fresca en un número menor a 1.715 como
por ejemplo 1.680 observen que en este
caso tenemos la línea en 1700 y la señal
aparece después así que este espectro y
r
pertenece a la acetona no con jugada de
la derecha espero que esto les ayude a
entender un poco cómo analizar algunos
espectros y r